foreign
[Music]
independent just by virtue of the fact
that the parties have gone so far to the
right so far to the left that it's very
difficult to identify with one
particular party I'm a Democrat I um
have I think Social Justice and um like
a lot of progressive issues have been
like closely intertwined in my life you
know I think when you say you identify
with one party or the other people come
to a lot of assumptions on every policy
issue and so in that vein sometimes
people don't want to identify one or the
other I I would say that I'm more
Republican I feel like I'm more
independent just because I feel like
people especially like with social media
they kind of treat it as like I stand on
one line
socially I find myself it's the
traditional cop-out answer but I do
think there's some Merit in being
fiscally Republican socially liberal I
identify Democrat
only on social issues is the only reason
why I would identify with it because
there's certain
things that I can't
allow myself to agree with that I think
the Republican party for instance on
like I don't know women's rights
marriage equality certain things I just
can't sign up for it but doesn't mean
that I agree with everything that the
Democratic party does I'm all about
personal freedom personal Liberty and I
think the Republican Party wins on those
issues that's not to say that the party
doesn't have its flaws that's not to say
that I don't agree with some more
Progressive issues I don't like to
identify with either or just because I
feel like depending on the policy like
my could change I know like a lot of
Republicans are in favor of school
choice I personally supported coming
from a poor area and having
opportunities to go to school in better
areas but when you look at other issues
like immigration reform I would consider
myself more liberal and so I feel like
it varies on the issue if it's between
the two Democrats because I don't like
Republicans viewpoints pretty much I am
registered unenrolled but I lean more
democratic I'm kind of in between I
guess there's some things that I would
put on both sides but I don't know like
maybe on a spectrum sort of near the
middle but maybe a little bit more right
I'm not sure I actually don't identify
as either I would definitely say that
I'm like definitely left places like
Harvard and a lot of these top schools
there isn't enough representation of
conservatives and Republicans and there
are two parties in Washington there are
two parties in government and so
um I want to be a smart representation
of Republicans
[Music]